Hi, I'm Bella Thorne and I've been bullied my whole life.
It started when I was about five or six and it was before school...
...because I spoke Spanish, that's my first language,...
....and everybody called me weird because I didn't speak like everybody else.
So, I completely dropped Spanish to fit in so that people would stop calling me names,...
...and now I have to try to retake Spanish because I want to learn it.
And that's the cause of bullying.
Then it continued, just for something different.
It was because I wasn't able to read as everybody else.
People called me dumb and stupid.
And now, to this very day,...
...I get really nervous so that I can barely read in front of a large crowd.
And that was because I was dyslexic.
I'm taking a stand against bullying because it's wrong and hurtful,...
...and it can harm everybody in different ways.
Will you take one with me?